major development on the wuhan covid lab
leak investigation
the official who led the probe that
president biden then
shut down says his team found almost
nothing to suggest the virus occurred
naturally
we were finding that uh despite the
claims of our scientific community
uh including the national institutes of
health and dr
fauci's nye aid organization
that there was almost no evidence that
supported the natural
zoonotic uh uh
you know evolution or uh
source of coban 19. the data
disproportionately stacked up as we
investigated that it was coming out of a
lab or some
supernatural source and house lawmakers
are preparing to introduce
two new bills aimed at china today one
establishing a commission
investigating the origins of the
pandemic the other
allowing americans who lost loved ones
to sue beijing
republicans are pressuring president
biden to hold
china accountable the evidence
i think strongly suggests that this
virus escaped from one of the two
institutes of virology in wuhan china
what matters most to me is that the
american people get answers
was the chinese government responsible
for unleashing
the worst pandemic in a century on the
world
we need to hold china accountable
instead of rewarding them
and they need to be held accountable for
financially for what they have done to
the world
dan bongino to you for senator tom
cotton who we just showed
was talking about that virology lab in
wuhan
in january of last year
yeah listen i don't want to hear another
peep from a liberal or a talking head
media buffoon
ever again about a conspiracy theory
okay they never
produce evidence about any of this stuff
you had the peepee hoax remember that
with the collusion thing there was no
evidence of that either
but that became an international scandal
there was no evidence that this thing
ever came from a bat or a pangolin or
whatever
we still haven't produced the animal
it's amazing how we have a worldwide
pandemic and don't have one single
sample
from a bat or pangolin or others now
what's even more infuriating about this
is
anyone with common sense who is outside
the liberal media ecosystem would have
seen from the start
that this was probably a lab league
let's just walk through some basic facts
folks in case you missed these and you
were reading the new york times
we had a lab in wuhan where the pandemic
originated
that studied bat coronaviruses where a
coronavirus
got out and they studied gain of
function experiments to make them more
powerful
and the lab had security problems in the
past
must be natural that's what liberals
came to the conclusion
this has got to be one of the most
infuriating stories
in modern history and it's all the
media's fault one more quick thing on
this
what was incredible about it is when the
chinese government put out propaganda
don't you dare say that this was a lab
league someone ate bat soup
and then people commented about people
eat bat soup
everybody was called a racist for even
commenting on bat soup for a story that
was obviously chinese propaganda this is
an infuriating mess
the media should just wrap up shop and
go home
well that's a part of the problem that
dan just pointed out jillian is that all
the people who wouldn't even allow
whether it's media talking heads or
nancy pelosi calling it remember the
trump virus
you weren't allowed to talk about
something that was logical
that they shut you down i don't think
the problem here is so much a liberal
versus a conservative divide
in america i think the problem here is
willingness to hold
again to hold china's feet to the fire
and hold the government
responsible for this i will say the
reporting from david asher that sound
bite
from the former state department
official you played a moment ago matches
up precisely with what an intelligence
community official told me
yesterday which is that the skeptics of
the natural theory here
have remained skeptical because there
has yet to be proven
any evidence of that initial animal to
human transmission they say that a year
and a half now
into the pandemic a year and a half from
when that initial case
would have emerged it's very unusual
that they have not identified
the specific case at this point sars one
sars2
it all happened within a matter of
months that they were able to identify
the initial case so the fact that we
don't have that here
is very telling another quick point here
um the world health organization who the
u.s has been relying on
to investigate to gather underlying data
just revised its own estimate this week
it's not getting a lot of attention in
the press for some reason
they have been telling us for the last
six months that they believe 3.4 million
people have died the world over from
covid this week they said it's likelier
two to three times that amount of people
so we're now looking at
seven to 11 million people dead around
the world
the question is now how you even be
that's double the holocaust
how do you hold how do you even think
about holding the chinese government
responsible for that well you can't rely
on the world health organization because
they've lied on behalf from day one
for communist china number one number
two the team that went in
made from the world health organization
that went in to investigate the virus
their conclusion was that
the virus was imported in frozen food
into china
that that was a more likely conclusion
than the lab leak
and that came out just a couple of
months ago jessica i want you to listen
to this
zeke emanuel dismissing the importance
of investigating china take a listen to
this
the real issue is not how did this
happen the real issue is
how do we protect ourselves from the
next pandemic
and how do we have a kind of early
warning system
the real issue is not how did this
happen actually that is the very issue
because how do you prevent one unless
you figured out what went wrong in the
first place
in china i absolutely agree with that
and i think most liberals even the ones
that dan was talking about would
disagree with zika emanuel
on this one and say that we need to know
the origins and that's why president
biden
is now backing a thorough investigation
kind of taking things out of the hands
of the who and saying
we need to look into this further
ourselves there will be bipartisan
agreement for that i think the two new
sets of sanctions or bills that would
punish the chinese
are also going to be welcome if
certainly the figures that jillian is
talking about from the new report are
true and i see no reason to believe that
they aren't
considering how coveted works with
pre-existing conditions that we've lost
that many people
they absolutely need to be held
accountable for that but there is one
element that we haven't discussed yet
that i think is important
to why people were so averse to going
with the lab lake theory it's that it
was also being tied
to frankly a lot of things that sounded
pretty racist we know that the attacks
against eight
i heard you've grown there dan but it's
true so
let's talk about acts of nonsense this
is just so stupid it's only the a block
dan just give me a chance it's the first
no it's dumb
it's not system
they want to make sure they don't die
from a coroner it's just stupid okay
wuhan virus
kung flu people asian reporters being
called
kung flu those things are racist the
rise in attacks against members
of the aipi community that is also
racist people just beating people
indiscriminately on the street because
they are asian
during a pandemic where the president
united states of america
is saying china china china about it is
racist there is a way to talk about the
lab
dan i didn't cut you off and i really
disagreed with jessica i want to get i
wanted you
made your point i want to get greg in
here though
wuhan plague go um the reason why we
didn't hold china accountable and we
being our major institutions is because
it wasn't trump
so it was a political decision if you if
you actually legitimately
blame the people responsible then you
couldn't blame the person you hate most
uh even if and i disagree with jessica
completely on this
even if you found those terms racist
that does not
excuse your dereliction of journalistic
duty
you're supposed to pursue a story
whether the story is surrounded by any
if the story is
real and it's plausible and this one is
plausible the occam's razor the simplest
explanation
if you're in a small town and an
explosion goes off
maybe check the bomb factory don't go to
the ice cream parlor
and that's what this is i learned my
lesson that if i want to start a
pandemic
i'm going to through my lab i'm going to
open my lab next to a wet market
because apparently that's plausible
deniability and by the way
wet markets are getting a bad rap all a
wet market is
is a farmer's market with a few extra
exotic animals
it's called wet because they hose down
the floor
just like the bars that jillian hangs
out in dc
and the thing is even at eight months
pregnant yes
it's it's disgusting how you corrupt and
last
the ezekiel thing bothers but that's not
the last thing second to the last thing
the ezekiel thing he doesn't mind
because he's going to be dead soon
don't you remember him the king of
euthanasia
he's saying you know i don't want to
live that long do you remember he's that
guy so it's like he doesn't really care
lastly now shut up do you remember the
taunt the time
article about how all our major
institutions the media the chamber of
commerce the tech
giants they all worked together to uh
unseat trump and they even bragged about
it
they called it you know an in the dark
type conspiracy this is now a
reoccurring trend and it's it's showing
up
in so many places that a coalition of
powerful forces
when they decide to manipulate an
outcome they'll
do it so they did it with the russian
collusion thing they did it with hunter
biden those were tech giants and the
press
they did it with voter fraud that we if
you say and
if you mention voter fraud on youtube or
twitter just see how quickly that story
disappears okay
so right right now we're seeing this
happen with this story and we're seeing
the outcome of it which is possibly
many more people died because a bunch of
people got together
and they decided that this was a bad
idea because of one word
trump was right and you couldn't admit
it has nothing to do with racism it's
it's just it's sad and it's and even on
top of that the impeachment circus
as the pandemic spread assisted china
and the virus and that's not racist
either
well actually greg it wasn't even just
trump because his non-political
appointees his own intel people who were
not appointed by him
were telling fox news and others the
same thing a year ago so what you don't
even ha
you know what i mean it was not only
trump's people that were saying this a
year and a half ago
but he was the one that he was the one
that mattered right right
he was the one that mattered and he said
it was the incompetence of china and
nothing else that did this mass
worldwide killing and he said that
in may 2020 oh but it was the trump
virus
right not the wuhan virus not the virus
out of china
that killed more than three and a half
million people around the globe
lab lab lab hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else